c'est celle là c'est bien elle
il ya plusieurs fermes il yal douceur
painter charger ces trois termes
signifie en fait les personnes qui
recharge les trottinettes électriques
moi le fait que je sois boulanger et
douceur je le vois comme un complément
vraiment ça me permet de payer déjà
d'économiser pour la suite pour
différents projets pour partir en
vacances pour payer mes loisirs pour
vraiment voir un confort supplémentaire
[Musique]
je serai dans cette boulangerie du coup
le mardi mercredi jeudi vendredi samedi
et j'ai mon week-end dimanche lundi bon
il est 16h15 et là on va aller chercher
des trottinettes suis directement leur
de commencer la récolte c'est parti
[Musique]
on va commencer directement notre notre
recherche de trottinettes à recharger
sachant que là on va regarder la carte
puis ensuite on va pouvoir se faire un
avis sur on commence par cookie et
parcours je suis regardé à plusieurs on
a eu ni si tu vois une minute celle là
elle est au niveau de cordeliers alors
là et on va aller chercher à notre
premier véhicule perd 3 à 2 il faut on
va la récupérer
qu'est ce qu'elle est bien sûr ma carte
oui
qu'elle ait atteint 16% de madrid on
cale à bien tourner un là celle-là elle
a bien tourné
un petit scan
collectif c'est tout bon
là on est bon
voilà récupérer ma technique est très
simple
grandmont du don
tac
là j'ai fait ma première partie je
connais vous m'avez qui
je positionne ma trottinette sur le
devant je tire mon guidon par le bras
et c'est fini
c'est parti
je la vois pas
elle est où
on la passe et la voilà on est tu le
suis sûr qu'on regarde on va regarder
aller là c'est bon je sais si c'est
normal en fait
21 heures tu as bien
c'est toi qu'à celle là et c'est un
déplacement pour rien c'est pas grave on
va regarder on a d'autres dans le centre
c'est un petit peu un jeu faut être le
premier arrivé à auprès de la
trottinette mai
on va pas se mettre en danger ça vaut
pas la peine je suis inconvénients que
je vois c'est que bien évidemment ce
sont des horaires il faut avoir la
motivation je pense pour pour le faire
[Musique]
pour faire clair sur cette trottinette
on voit elle a été cassée on peut voir
que la voie était désert que désaxé donc
elle est toujours connecté mais désaxé
c'est un véhicule endommagé j'ai pas à
la prendre
juste à mettre le problème j'ai même
mettre une photo
n'as tu fais la patrouille de la
maintenance
tu fais je suis bon je fais je le fais
gratuitement parce que en fait ce qui en
fait moi je pars du principe que si on
veut que les troupiers de continuer à
durer en fait si on veut continuer à
coups de notre travail de douceur hunter
on doit avoir aussi cet acte c'est à
dire d'être vigilants par rapport à la
flotte
il y avait si on veut plus trop tiède
qui resté très longtemps déchargé dans
la rue pouvait avoir une augmentation
prix aujourd'hui c'est plus le cas
l'opérateur va proposer 5 euros l'autre
va proposer 6 euros lot 3 euros le prix
minimum pour quelqu'un qui va charger la
trottinette aujourd'hui c'est 5 euros à
lyon vous en arrivez à la base si on
veut j'appelle ça la base mais la maison
en fait sur toute mise en charge puis
après recharge et du coup cette nuit et
puis on demain matin faudra les
débrancher pour les redéployer en fait
[Musique]
actuellement 80 16 et on va commencer à
sortir des trottinettes pour entamer la
déploiement matinale alors le
déplacement ça consiste à déployer des
droits thiney dur des lieux prédéfinis
par les marques
il ya des gens qui y voit la salle de
sport et à des gens qui font du cerf
donc en fait nous on est là on va à les
déployer sur celui là comme on peut le
voir en fait on a l'information
tous les gens à une photo de comment on
doit déposer les trottinettes et c'est
parti
et hop un scan tacle c'est bon là on a
déposé les quatre pour voir si tout est
bien déposé on va regarder l'historique
c'est terminé maintenant ils sont
disponibles pour les utilisateurs donc
la passe plus qu'à attendre en fait les
utilisateurs de les utiliser de bière
vide et des batteries nouveau cycle qui
commence du coup ce soir c'est à dire
pour récupérer le trop tiède des charges
et les recharges on redéploie et ainsi
de suite ma tâche est terminé ma mission
est terminée maintenant là je me
recouche et environs en deux à trois
heures pour me relever un peu plus tard
pour enchaîner ma journée de travail et
en boulangerie simplement
[Musique]